what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to young woman says she's
been ghosted eight times and has no idea
why before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos also
if you've watched three or more of my
videos and you have not subscribed okay
menu
beef
beef okay
so hit the subscribe button please i
need to afford rent please
i feel like there's no reason why i
shouldn't have a relationship i am the
type of person that when someone shows
me affection i'm all in i like to text
all the time i like to just talk to them
all the time the first
okay
here's the thing
guys guys don't like to talk all the
time
they don't enjoy it it's a problem i'm a
chit chatter don't get me wrong
i i like to chit chat but yeah guys
i forgot my ex-boyfriend said something
to me where he's like i'd like you to be
around
but also not like there
but not there
yeah i'm gonna continue question i
always ask is do you have a girlfriend
do you have a girlfriend i met a guy we
had a great date and then a week later i
went to his house and made him breakfast
so i went upstairs to his bathroom and i
saw two different types of shampoo one
was for a woman and one was for a man oh
no
i have never
how did you find that miss
how did you i gotta ques okay i'm gonna
just contin how did you find that were
you looking
were you
were you looking through his his stuff
okay
and i got suspicious i just said are you
sure you don't have a girlfriend he goes
no i already told you that when i look
over at his calendar and i see a girl's
name
on a friday and it is circled and when i
left i said are you sure you don't have
a girlfriend and then that's when he
goes to me
a medic well
yeah i
okay i had a seminar named brooklyn and
we hit it off at dinner i felt like we
had a connection so of course i asked
the question that i always ask do you
have a girlfriend and he said no we
talked a few more times okay but this is
what you have to understand you're going
into something
basically accusing the guy
of having a girlfriend he could be a
nice guy and not have one
but
guys don't like to be accused of stuff
when they don't they don't know you
and that's that's the problem you can't
go into something
assuming someone else has bad intentions
okay and okay
and i asked him one more time do you
have a girlfriend and he didn't answer
and i followed up with another text that
said do you still want to go on the date
that we planned and he never takes me
back so that's when i knew i was ghosted
i need dr
ma'am
you can't keep he
okay if he if he answers it the first
time and he says he doesn't have a
girlfriend you can either choose to
believe him
or not believe him but if he's gonna lie
to you
asking him the same question ten times
isn't gonna get you a better answer or
the the truth
okay if he's gonna lie to you he's gonna
lie to you you can't control that that
is not in your control filter help me
figure out why i keep attracting men who
are going to ghost me who are lying and
who have girlfriends because i'm done
with the guys who are ghosting and i
need a relationship
okay so you have to have a theory
why eight times why do you think people
have bailed on you eight times i have no
theory because i am beautiful i'm smart
i'm talented i'm going after my goals
okay men don't care about your career
i'm just
it's not a nice reality right i'm a hard
worker and i always
you want guys to be attracted to your
ambition you know you want guys to be
attracted
to
you know how hard you work and your
goals and all that stuff they're not
guys
i wish that'd be great it'd be a bonus
for me
but like when we look at a ceo that's
attractive to us
like those behaviors and those traits
when they look at a ceo
of that's a woman
they might think it's cool
but it's kind of like the equivalent i
heard fresh and fit say it's the
equivalent of a shoe collection and
that's really true
guys don't brag about your shoe
collections i don't i do not care if you
have the latest jordans i really don't
not even a little bit
i can cook just a little bit i mean
maybe two or three things but
i mean i'm nice so i have no theories i
don't know why they're going to see me
okay
but let me ask you this let's say you
get up in the morning okay
and you go
and stop by the grocery store
and
you get in a just a
big
screaming argument with somebody over
there that works at the grocery store
you get in your car
and you drive to the cleaners okay
and you get in a big screaming argument
with somebody over there
let's say you run by the church where
you do some volunteer work
and you get getting a big screaming
argument with somebody over there okay i
think dr phil is trying to say ma'am
ma'am you're the problem
it's you
is a pattern developing here yeah
would you say there's a common
denominator
maybe me maybe the people are not having
a good day
well
what's
at every one of those places and the
crazy thing is she's pretty and she's
pleasant she seems pleasant she just
needs to chill
i just chill a little bit i wonder if
she ever found someone what's her name
i'll google it
you've been ghosted eight times yes and
you're
involved in all eight of them yes
so is it possible there's something
you're doing
that's alienating people is that just
i'm not saying i just met you i don't
know i'm just asking i i no i honestly
it's because a lot of these guys who are
on dating apps have girlfriends already
or they're talking to someone already
and i find out and they don't like that
really oh
of course
guys if it's a
i don't understand if it's a guy you
want to date if he's attractive and he
has a lot of things going for him you
don't think other women are going to
notice
of course he's talking to someone else
do you want to be with someone
that no one else wants if a guy has the
option
he's going to talk to more than one girl
until he picks one
it's not a fun reality right it's just
you know how it is you don't consider
that it's something you're doing
no
no
how is that something i'm doing when
they had a girlfriend i know but you
asked him five times if he has a
girlfriend
believe him or don't believe him but
don't keep asking what does that do for
anyone well let's take a look okay
this is
we'll call this ghost one
okay april 13th
ghost
i'd be honored to take a pretty girl
like yourself out
brittany
i have a question before we go on a date
do you have a girlfriend be honest
ghost i don't have a girlfriend
after their date
brittany i had a great time
ghost i did too you have a beautiful
smile
britney are you sure you don't have a
girlfriend
i don't want to start liking you and
find that out ghost
i answered that question already okay
you know what's funny about this
you're communicating to a guy that you
date guys with girlfriends because why
else would you keep asking like there's
no other reason to keep asking unless
it's happened to you before that's why
when girls say to a guy they say
i
like i don't want hookups like no
hookups on here you're saying like i
you're saying i have hooked up with guys
off of here before
because why else would you say that
unless it's happening
yes you did sorry
good night
after breakfast date april 25th brittany
hey is everything okay
ghost yes why are you asking
because you haven't really been texting
no this is so needy this is so needy
oh no
oh no also if you're snoring that's my
dog she sleeps a lot
well i've been busy with work
are you sure you're not talking to
someone or have a girlfriend
or if you don't want to talk to me
anymore just tell me i'm a big girl
ghost oh my god
i just don't what do you expect to get
out of that
do you think a liar is gonna magically
stop lying to you because you asked the
same question 20 times oh my goodness
when you see that
written out what do you think about that
i think that he had a girlfriend and he
didn't
tell i feel like some of the people on
these tv shows are trolling half the
time
i swear
um okay well
um
i i just have one take away from this
video and i know i've said this like 10
times
asking the same ques let's let's assume
the worst all those guys were liars all
those guys have have girlfriends asking
those guys the same question over and
over and over and over again isn't going
to get you a different answer
liars are going to lie to you that's
life but if you go into things assuming
everyone else is bad
and out of like you're afraid that
something bad is gonna happen
i'm sorry in dating bad things are
probably going to happen
it's just part of life
but
are you gonna
live your life out of fear and afraid
that something bad might happen
anything that's worth half having
is worth taking a risk so let me know
what you guys think in the comments um
was she crazy or
am i am i trippin am i trippin don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell i'll talk to you
guys next time